No,
and so when,
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settled down,
it isn't because they're making a lot of
noise being in pain is because they're
running around like wild baboons having
a blast and disrupting things like mad,
you know,
and so you got kids,
you got to settle down,
you know,
like quit having so much fun and it's,
it's kind of awful that you do that,
but,
but you do and that's because the
emotions and the motivations have to be
brought into like a relationship with
one another within the person.
So that,
you know,
one thing I remember with my son who is
quite,
he's quite disagreeable by temperament,
which is actually a good thing as far as
I'm concerned,
although it brings its own challenges.
And so with my daughter when she was
misbehaving,
she was pretty agreeable and uh,
you know,
if she was misbehaving I can basically
just look at her and then she'd quit,
you know,
but my son was like,
that was just nothing.
You're looking at me.
It's like,
no,
that's just not gonna go anywhere man.
And so then I'd like tell them to stop
and that really wasn't having much of an
effect either.
He just sort of made me laugh or runaway
or whatever.
I mean he was a tough little rat and you
know,
what I would do with him is he would be
doing something and it interfered and
he'd get upset and you know,
angry.
And so then I get them to sit on the
steps and I told him,
this is when he was about to.
I said,
look,
you're going to sit on the steps.
That's time out.
You're going to sit on the steps until
you've got control of yourself and you
can come back and be and play the game
again.
I basically said,
be a civilized human being and then
you're welcome again.
And so he'd sit on the steps.
It was so interesting to watch because
he was just enraged.
She'd sit there like,
have you ever seen a two year old had a
temper tantrum?
It's really quite the bloody phenomena.
If you ever saw an adult do that,
you'd like,
you'd call nine one one right away.
It's like,
oh my God.
And I've seen adults do that,
you know,
because people say with borderline
personality disorder will have temper
tantrums and it's like,
man,
you want to be about 30 feet away from
that person.
That's for sure.
It's really.
But in kids it's like,
well first of all,
they're only this long.
So how much trouble can they really
cause?
But it's like,
you know,
they're just completely gone there.
Like on the floor of their face is red.
They're just furious,
like way more furious than you ever get
if you are even vaguely socialized
there,
just outraged.
And they're kicking and hitting the
ground and like,
it's like a little epileptic fit of
anger,
you know,
they're completely controlled by their
rage.
And we took care of one kid for awhile
who he was actually a pushover,
that kid you could get him to behave by,
you know,
kind of shaking your finger at him.
But his mother thought he was really
tough because he had her.
He had her figured out and one of the
things he would do is have a temperature
temper tantrum.
And during the temper Tantrum,
he would hold his bloody breath until he
turned blue.
It's like,
try that,
like you know,
as that's your homework,
go home and go home and have a temper
tantrum and while you're doing it,
hold your breath until you actually turn
blue.
It's like you won't be able to do it.
You don't have the willpower of a two
year old,
that's for sure.
That little varmint man,
he just have a fit.
Then he'd hold his breath and then he
turned blue.
It was like,
wow,
that's,
that's amazing.
And we would just like,
let them do it,
you know,
he turned blue and everybody would be
gone and he'd come out of it,
you know,
and it didn't work.
So he just quit doing it.
I think he did it like twice and he
figured out,
oh well that's a lot of work for very
little outcome.
And you know,
it's not like two year olds are stupid.
They're,
they're not stupid.
They're probably smarter than you,
but they're not civilized by any stretch
of the imagination.
And so anyways,
back to my son,
I'd put them on the steps and he'd be
like,
oh,
it's just like in other aged and trying
to get himself together,
you know?
And I'd wait a few,
few,
I kind a strict rule which was as soon
as you're done,
you're welcome again.
So it's completely under your control.
You,
you get yourself calmed down,
you come and talk to me again.
If you're calm enough.
So I like you,
then you're welcome back in the family.
No grudge or nothing.
And so it's harder than you think.
Like people think they like their kids.
It's like don't be thinking that they're
hard to like they're little monsters and
they're very,
very pushy and provocative.
And so lots of parents do not like their
children and they do terrible things to
them their whole life.
So it's no joke and it's a very common.
And you know,
that was Freud's observation,
fundamental observation that a lot of
psychopathology is rooted in the family
and you can be sure of that.
You know?
And when you hear about some mother
who's done something terrible to her
child,
which happens reasonably frequently,
you know perfectly well that she has a
very terrible capacity to discipline.
The child is just provoked her and
provoked or unprovoked or provoked or
unprovoked or and it just happens to be
a day where her new boyfriend left and
she's quite hung over and she got fired
and it's like that's the wrong data
provoker and then she does something
that is not good and you read about it
and you think,
well,
how could that happen?
How could anyone do that?
It will.
That's how they do it.
And so and kids are very provocative,
just like little chimps,
chimps will.
The adolescents will like throw little
pebbles and sticks at the sleeping
larger males and bug them.
And that teasing,
which it is,
that teasing turns into full fledged
dominance challenge behavior.
Once the adolescent males get big enough
to do it.
And so when you're being provoked by a
child,
which they provoke your time,
they're trying to figure out,
well,
where are you exactly?
What happens if I do this?
What happens if I do this,
you know,
and how else are they going to figure it
out?
Anyways,
he'd sit on the steps and just,
he's just enraged and trying to control
himself and I've watched that and then,
you know,
I come back after about two minutes or
whatever and he'd still be around,
I'd say,
well are,
you know,
have,
have you got yourself under control?
Are you ready to get off the steps?
And then,
you know,
he'd get himself under control and then
he'd come back and you know,
he'd be contrite and then I would like
him right away.
You know,
you got to watch that,
you know,
because you don't like being dominated
by a two year old.
No one does.
And so if the child hasn't mastered
himself and started to act in accordance
with the prevailing social norms,
you won't like them while you think,
oh yeah,
I will because you know,
I'm a good person.
It's like,
no,
you won't and no,
you're not a good person.
So don't be thinking about that at all.
It's just not true.
So when he was contrite,
then he'd come and we'd just go on like
nothing had happened because that's what
you want to do,
right?
As soon as you get compliance,
especially if the compliance is in the
best interest of the child,
you want to reward it instantly,
right?
That's the right thing to do because so
then and,
and you could just see him gaining
control over himself.
And so really what was happening is his,
in his mind,
in his brain will say there was a war
between the psyche,
the ego that was starting to become
integrated and starting to become a
continuous person,
an identity,
and it's fragile in two year olds and it
can be disrupted all the time.
And it is.
That's why they're so hyper emotional.
It's fragile,
that little eagle and it doesn't have a
lot of power.
And so what you want to do is reward it
when it wins.
You know when it,
when he gets control over the underlying
motivations,
you want to say,
hey,
good work man,
good work kid.
You did it.
You know,
you got yourself under control way to
be.
And the kids really happy about that
because it's actually not that much fun
to have a temper tantrum.
It's exhausting,
you know,
it takes you over question.
Oh,
just pat on the head or you know,
that's good.
You're kind word,
you know,
or,
or whatever earth.
Yeah.
Notice it.
Pay Attention.
That's it.
And that's a great.
It's a great thing to know with people
like in your relationships here.
Here's the key to a good relationship.
It's not the only one,
but watch your person carefully,
carefully,
and whenever they do something that you
would like them to do more of,
tell them that that was really good and
mean it.
And it's not manipulative because if
it's manipulative it won't work.
It's like you have to say,
wow,
I'm so glad you did that.
Did you have to be precise?
Here's what you just did that I thought
was great and Oh boy,
that's so nice that you've noticed.
I can't believe they could notice.
It's like,
you know,
you do that 20 times and the person will
be like the rat.
That's just pushing the lever for
cocaine.
You know,
so,
but no,
I'm serious.
It's skinner established this bf skinner
noticed this a long time ago.
Reward is intensely useful in terms of
modifying behavior,
but the problem is is that it's really
hard to notice when things are going
right,
right?
Because you're kind of prime to notice
when things are going wrong and so you
use threat and punishment more often as
agents of,
of shaping the people that you're around
because you know when everything's going
right,
it's like,
what are you going to say?
Everything's going right.
It turns to zero.
You just assume it and that's,
that's not good.
That's not good.
You want to pay attention and if the
person,
your children,
your wife,
your whoever,
your mother,
your sister,
if you want them to,
if you want to rectify your
relationships with them,
and I'm not saying to do this in a
manipulative wait,
won't work,
but if they do something that's
promoting harmony and peace and
goodwill,
it's like attend to it.
Tell them that you noticed.
It's like it's so useful and you have to
get rid of your grudges and your
resentment to do that.
Right?
Because you don't want you to kind of
mad at your sister and then you know
what,
if she does something good,
you think there is no god damn way,
I'm going to reward you for that.
So you ignore her when she does
something good.
It's like,
that's brilliant.
That is because then you've just
punished her for doing what you want.
And people do that with their kids all
the time,
you know,
because they let the kids dominate them.
Then they get resentful.
Then the kid will run up to them to show
them something that's kind of
spectacular and they'll,
they're not happy.
They'll think,
oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm working.
You know,
little kid has all sad about that and
he's just learned something so.
And it's not perhaps what you want them
to learn.
And so you have to keep your,
your relationship with your children
pristine.
And that means that you can't hold a
grudge or resent them.
And that means that you have to help
them learn how to behave so that you
liked them.
And that way if they,
if you like them and you're kind of
sensible and maybe your partner also
likes them,
so you know,
you got a consensus going there,
there's a reasonable possibility that
other people will actually liked them
too,
including other children.
And then the world will open up to them,
you know,
then you'll bring them to people's
houses and the people will actually
smile at them and give them a pat on the
head and instead of thinking,
oh my God,
that Brad's coming to visit again,
I wonder what will break this time,
you know?
And that's just a horrible thing for
your child to experience repetitively in
situation after situation.
All they learned is that adults have a
false smile,
but they're really lying all the time.
God,
it's like a bit of hell.
And there's a lot of children who are
trapped in that.
It's really awful to see.
I can see kids like that when I walked
down the street,
you know,
it's like their little doomed things and
there they are and you know,
they're screwed in 15 different ways and
there's no way out of it.
It's really awful,
so I would not recommend that you do
that.
It's better to notice that you're a bit
of a monster or a lot of a monster and
notice that you are much happier with
the people around you when they behave
in accordance with reasonable source
social norms and then you actually feel
genuinely connected to them and you want
to work on their behalf so that
everything out.
But if you think you're a good person
and that you'd never do anything that
was harmful to your children,
then you can just forget about that
because you'll never take it seriously
enough to actually learn.
So.
Alright.
So anyways,
we live inside this story as far as I
can tell and you know,
we kind of put the story together inside
us to begin with and that happens
between two and four when you're
integrating those motivations and
emotions into a relatively functional
unity.
Right?
And,
and,
and that does happen between two and
four.
If you don't have your kids socialized
by the time,
therefore you might as well just forget
it.
And I know that sounds terribly
pessimistic and all of that,
but I know the literature on trying to
rectify antisocial behavior in children
and after the age of four,
it's virtually impossible no matter what
you do.
And the reason for that is that kids who
are still acting like two year olds when
they're for that,
you know,
they're twice as old as a two year old.
That's a lot of difference like four
year olds in adult as far as the two
year old is concerned.
And so if the four year old is still
acting like a two year old,
that's really not good.
And other four year olds will come up
and you know,
do a little play invitation like the dog
the,
the kid a two year old,
four year old has no idea how to react
to that.
And so the more mature kid thinks,
oh,
well how about a play with you?
And then that kid is isolated from the
peers and after four year mostly
socialized by your peers.
And so you just fall farther and farther
and farther behind.
You're more and more alienated.
You're more bitter and angry and no
wonder and it's just not.
You can't rectify it so,
so,
so that's useful to know.
It's like your job from two to four is
to turn your child,
help turn your child into a functional
unity and buy three.
They should be functional enough as a
unity within themselves so that they can
concentrate on a voluntary goal for some
reasonable length of time,
which is also why it's useful to let
them spend some time alone so that they
can learn to amuse themselves because if
they can use themselves,
they're not going to be able to play
with other kids and then by three
they're sorted together enough.
So if another three year old comes
along,
they can at least play in parallel and
may also start,
may be able to start playing a
cooperative game.
And so that's often a fantasy game,
you know,
pretend.
And so what the kids will do it.
Sometimes they mediated verbally,
but sometimes it's,
it's more acted out.
It's a combination of the two.
They'll assign each other rules.
They'll do this with you too.
It's like let's have a tea party.
Well,
what does that mean?
it means let's sit down and act out the
act of sharing food and see if we can
get that right.
That's what the kid saying.
I'll have a little tea party.
You know,
it's very important because human being
shared food,
like this is a major thing to get right
man.
And so the kid will say,
well you be the mom and I'll be the dad
and you know,
we'll make little fort and that'll be
our house and we'll go in there and
we'll run our roles and you know,
we're acting out,
we're acting out family.
And,
and if,
if were both reasonably civilized as
three year olds,
we can concentrate on that goal.
We can establish that little fictional
world.
We can,
we can negotiate our mutual goal and
then we can run the simulation.
And that's what kids are doing when
they're pretending it's bloody
brilliant.
That's play man.
It's like,
it's brilliant.